I do know you and Cherry I do know hey I do as a matter of fact
know you and Cherry were not speaking at this time because she
had some very upset conversations with me concerning you about
that time. Yeah, that's what I thought. Yeah, I'm not talking
about Pixie. I'm talking about his ex-wife. See, here here's
the thing. You didn't need Pixie to make the right decision in
this case. You already knew that he shared his ex-wife's
Okay, so now you're claiming that before this play the exact
same game that did. You played the exact same game that did the
exact same game did. I I hope everybody understands what he claimed
is the exact same thing. Exactly. What he claimed is that I would
have kept sweeping as in Cherry and I were dating before any
of these allegations came out. That is his allegation here. Well,
it's kind of a fact. Last time you got laid the root fact of
the matter is you're literally just saying it's a fact. It's
a fact. Here's here's an additional fact. How much money do you
have that you could bet on this? How much money do you have that
you could bet on this? Here's an additional fact. None. My channel
is monetized. Here's here's an additional fact. Here's an additional
fact. I don't know how you're going to make that one work.
They don't have to talk to each other. I'm saying Dan has to
be on the stream. Point.
Uh, viewership increase because Dan's going to be here. Oh, how
about
you get on with it? Stop wobbling. Yeah, I'll pull Io in. I How's
it going? Hi.
Hi. Um, so,
so my stream was Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So, it was uh it was Sunday.
Sunday's been on this whole thing of like we've I like downplayed
things
uh like way too much. I had I believe the exact take Quimman
did after the New Year's stream, right?
Uh so where was the downplaying there? I had the exact take he
did after the New Year's stream, right? I had the exact take
he did. No,
it's almost certainly not consensual. I almost certainly it's
not consensual.
No, I had the exact stream. No, I remember um and it's fine.
It's totally fine. I just remember specifically you saying that
you probably weren't going to burn bridges because of um uh because
you have other friends IRL who did similar things leaking nudes.
No, that is
I think what you're referring to I think I know what you're referring
to though. I think what you are referring to is when I said uh
would I let Destiny hop on the stream like for any like at any
point? Yeah, I have like a lot of weirdos on here. Like if you
want to be stream content, I'd let him hop on the stream. Excuse
me. No, but I don't that's not really why I'm here. Um so what
what about my stream was
uh I f it wasn't even you. It was just Sunday. There's some I
I can look at the comments Riyle sent me. Hold on. same like
sent me some I have the same opinion as I so why am I and she's
not
you have what same opinion I have the same opinion as Io I just
stated what it was a thing I didn't listen to I'll say what my
opinion is just to be clear
I'm going back to find this really quickly I think he doesn't
know he's legitimately poking you cuz I knew I got this clip
and I remember thinking this clip was dumb but we can go through
it and see what it was
okay I say what my what My uh take is real quick on Aaron.
On Aaron? Wait, on Aaron? That's what Yeah, that's what my stream
was. It wasn't about you. He's confused on that concept. Hold
on. Do you think my stream was about you?
I just I got sent clips from your stream. Hold on. Listen to
me at all. It wasn't about you literally at all. It was only
about
Straighter Aid.
Oh, so let me just say sides here. It took until Sunday had a
direct personal acquaintance being affected for him to care.
Yeah, that doesn't matter. I mean,
yeah. Uh, that's not true. I literally told Pixie that if she
like if she was going to make a public statement, I would be
on her side there um before the No, but what I'm saying though
is like,
is that it? You done? I was sorry, I paused to say that uh Sunday
said I like didn't care. Um, I had the exact same public opinion
that Queen and Chud did uh at the like after the like after maybe
in January, right before the videos dropped. I I was of the opinion
that you don't violate Pixie's consent to come forward with this
and that you don't like Molina's not pursuing something. Like
it was basically just we were waiting right now. We're in a holding
pattern and I messaged Pixie to let her know I was on her side
if she decided to come forward and then I was just waiting. Okay,
this was the point where I like had to make a public statement
then. Yeah.
Okay. Um, all about me. Just hold on. I'll probably I'll probably
also pull Sunday because I'm talking about Yeah. Just really
wanted to get Dan in here, right?
Before you do that, before you do that, let me just say my overall
take on Aaron and then I can let it go and that'll be it. Okay.
I don't Hold on. I don't I didn't hear your take on Aaron, so
I don't even know that I would disagree with it. That was my
entire stream. Sunday just came in and said this line. He was
only he he came in for a talk after my stream was over.
So, I just think that I think this should be said in general.
This is just my take. I think uh other people might agree. Okay.
I like Aaron's uh presence. I think it's good that she's back
and she's doing whatever it is she's doing. Okay, that's enjoyable.
Um, I do think it is very awkward when like, you know, she's
on stream with you guys and then you guys start talking about
Destiny and she just silently
leaves. It's just very awkward.
Um, she doesn't need to like really explain herself. She just
has to say something. It's very awkward. So, I'm not saying she's
not saying she's evil. Like, I I can understand. I talked to
Riyle on stream about it and I was like, "Okay, I can understand
where her head might have been at that she took such actions,
right?" But it's just you can't say nothing because it is a big
glaring elephant famosis,
right? Hey, Sunday. Sure. Oh, yeah. That's all I have to say.
What do you think, Jay Talk? That she has to say something um
for that. I wanted her opinion something about I wanted her opinion
in those cases because she's been covering this stuff and she's
been covering it with Pisco. Um I don't remember we switched
over
No, it was about the most of the stream I think was about Pisco,
right? And Ethan Clark. Yeah, but it's still weird to just drop
like
it's just awkward like you got to it doesn't Hey Dan, I love
the uh I love the long hair. Looks really good on you. Dan has
long hair. Crazy. Yeah, long long jerk hair. Can't Can't see
him. He's right there. That's was the condition of me coming
in, right? Oh, yeah. No, I I said I was just baiting him on for
views and he won't come on. So, I I was talking about you, so
I figured I should drag you. Yeah. Cool. Do you uh disagree though,
Jaytock, that Straighter Age should, you know, it's just awkward,
right? Make some statement. I don't So, I think um acknowledge
the awkwardness. Maybe it's just no one saying anything and it's
this weird
Oh, I didn't get a weird vibe at all. I had no weird vibe whatsoever.
No, I didn't get that. I don't even notice I didn't even notice
that we switched to Destiny. She like left. I don't recall that
happening. But he started talking about how he's a and she just
silently left and that was it. Just very starkly. One second
there. Oh, Destiny.
Goodbye. No noise, but I felt the Discord disconnect noise in
my heart when she did it. Do we have a clip? Is that somewhere
in your VOD?
Um, um, I don't know. I don't I don't remember if I did. I just
reread all of her DMs with Sunday and Destiny and just talked
about, you know, the the process of what we know based on like
public
Oh, wait. So when she I just can we get a clip of her leaving
at the end or
it might even be in this thing because I think uh would it have
been Auggie again? Was Auggie Was Auggie starting again? I feel
like Auggie might have just Auggie sometimes he's got like Tourette's.
Augie can sit in a room for like 5 minutes and Auggie will say
or something like total death. He he'll like he'll just like
he's got you know and we love him for that. That's why we bring
him on. Oh Riyle has it. Riyle has it. Great. Thank you Riyle.
Yes.
She just silently leaves and no one notices. That's the That's
the weird thing. No one says bye, Aaron. Bye. See you later.
Let me see here.
Is this not going to load? Oh, it's going to crash. Cool. You
love kick. You love to see it on kick.
Okay. Well, we apparently don't have a
Exit.
Reload.
Oh, I know what happened. Oh, here we go.
Hear me out. I want to make one thing clear at the top is that
I want to focus on the YouTube uploads because the Twitch streaming
itself is too much of a great You just linked me the clip of
like when she gets here. What the [__] are you doing?
That's not
Oh, we don't like that clip, dude. 30,000 people like that. I'm
like, there's no way Tommy didn't see this. Like the I don't
know. I think it's fair to call Well, I mean, I don't think he's
literally like a But like I think it's, you know, it's a form
of consent violation. Yeah. Well, that's what I felt like the,
you know, the the commentary was is like he doesn't care about
a woman's consent, you know, in this context.
Bye. Peace. Peace.
Had she been had she been in this combo
she been there forever to Yeah. But when she's sitting here like
so Queen does this as well where he's like doing something else
and he'll like leave it muted and then eventually he'll leave
people. She interacts one more time for sure. I think it's called
I think he's literally like a like I literally I have a tweet
that has like 30,000 likes on Twitter calling for that whole
dude 30 people like there's only like I don't know I think it's
very I don't think he's literally like a but like you know it's
a violist
okay just for a while like at all she might have left because
of that I I don't know but I don't know what we were discussing
before this and she might have just been like oh well I think
she said something in chat like bye bye guys or something in
chat.
Okay.
Yeah. So,
right. So, it's just that awkward. Do I think she should have
to enter the Well, I do if we don't even notice her go. I don't
know. I don't know how awkward it is. I mean, we're pretty rioted
by Auggie talking about how he's a rapist.
Yeah, maybe you didn't notice. But I think that even if even
if Auggie and Queen noticed, they probably wouldn't say anything.
I mean, what are you going to do? Be awkward and cuz that's also
awkward because then you have to be the one that's like, "Oh,
well, you know,
if what's screaming?" I don't know if Queen would notice, but
even if he did, what's he going to do? Be like up
Sure. Well, I mean, awkward. I mean, I
where you're in a conversation for a long period of time. So,
I don't know when she joins. She'd been there for what? So this
is a long time 24 minutes. So you've been there for like an hour
and a half or an hour minutes, 25 minutes, right? So I think
um like if you feel the conversation shift away from what you
came on to discuss, you might just dip. Right. That's perfect.
What is she supposed to do? She's supposed to go, "Hey Augie,
shut the up about Destiny. I'm out of here, guys." I'm just saying
that I'm not saying she should have done it then. It's just that
the continuation of no one talking about it is just this I don't
know. The elephant keeps growing and it's very awkward to watch.
Talking about what?
Aaron having never said anything about anything of her likes
to talk about it a lot. If I had been around, I would have, but
I wasn't around to confront that
My advice to Straight Raider like months ago before she started
streaming was never address it because nobody who actually is
coming to your stream will ever care. There's nobody who's gonna
like stick around in good faith who cares about you addressing
it at all. Like there's nobody.
Yeah. Like the chat and stuff like you will not build a community
out of addressing it at all. Like you you won't like literally
most of us.
I think it's weird. Yes, it's very weird and it is going to come
out eventually. And then pretty much everybody who
or a big problem is Sorry, I don't mean to cut you off, Hiko.
That's my bad. You go ahead. My bad. It's just that um she is,
you know, and she's a great content creator, right? She's going
to build an audience who hasn't have no idea about the Destiny
stuff and then someone's going to get mad at her. Someone's going
to try to use it against her and be like, "Oh, you're like just
like Aerodite the Gizlane Maxwell." I don't know. Some kind of
uh thing like that,
you know? Like I'm not saying what she has to say. It's just
that she has said literally nothing that is making it a problem.
She could make like the tiniest statement, you know, it's just
nothing stays buried and if you look like you're running from
something, people are going to want to chase it. People in your
orbit is highly unethical. There is clear power dynamic there.
Do better, little bro. Not an orbit. Really? But cool. Thank
you for the donation.
Um, yeah, I disagree with you. I like I'm not going to say you're
wrong. I just disagree with the Why do you
Um because I don't think is based on information you have that
none of the rest of us do. No, I think she then why this could
be awkward. I think she basically like had somebody she thought
she was like close to a couple people and she wasn't that close
to them and they were ready to take what she shared in confidence
and use it for themselves. She shared that information to a bunch
of That's unfortunately like LA Did she share it to a bunch of
commentary YouTubers? Sunday. Yes. It wasn't just Sunday. Sunday
is not the only one. She shared it to, as far as I know, two
other people. Or did she go around and share it directly to commentary
YouTubers? Cuz I thought it was those other two people. Commentary
YouTubers, weren't they? Like Dorian. I thought it was I thought
it was Whiz and uh and Smug Bug were the only
funnily enough, they told me that she
um just yesterday. I asked both of them. I asked both of Well,
that's what she said in in her jams with Sunday, but they say
no. And so I'm like, "Who's lying?" And they're like, "I don't
know. We're all retarded." Literally, I communicated with Smug
Bug, so I my intuition based on memory is Smug's lying. But I
have to I have to check. Yeah. Weird.
And it's like a stupid lie. I I don't I don't know. It gets very
uh confusing. Like I don't think Straight Aid was trying to play
like 40 chess with people by doing this. I think she was genuinely
like confounded.
So, do you think that her why didn't she just speak to Ly or
literally any other normal people instead of a bunch of commentary
YouTubers? I don't think she as far as I know, she didn't speak
directly to those people. But maybe she did. Other options. I
don't understand. Well, okay, let me let me be real. My criti
my criticisms of her go way beyond like her just being like,
you know, sharing with all these people. It's also like her having
the audacity to try to coordinate this uh you know this law school
therapy payment thing behind the scenes playing both Destiny
and Pixie and trying to guide it in a a certain conclusion that
would quote unquote benefit everyone trying to talk Pixie out
of making a twit longer and go send me the really up thing is
I think for both of those people uh I'm I'm good with Pixie suing
Destiny But I'm guessing both Pixie and Destiny wish they just
done that instead. Wouldn't have been dropped. I'm not saying
that. But I'm saying probably both of those parties wish they'd
done it. And I think those were the two parties she was prioritizing.
I It doesn't It doesn't matter because she doesn't know. She
clearly doesn't know anything about how anything works, including
ideiation. It's just like so clear in the messages
um how how she really has faith in her ability to know what a
what a good outcome would be when she's not she doesn't have
um Wait, what do you think she said about Pixie's ideation?
She said that it wasn't um imminent enough for a wellness check.
Okay, that's not what she was saying and she's clarified that
to me like on a stream. Um, okay. What she was saying there was
not that uh it wasn't enough. She was saying that what Pixie
would do is tell people that it wasn't enough.
Like Pixie would Pixie's response to a wellness channel. I don't
care. I don't care about any of this. I don't know what this
was sent to me. What are you talking about? Yeah. Your DM straight
raid says that. Yeah. This is this is something this
Yeah. Holy. I might have. Yeah. Who Who cares if she clarified
who who who am I? I think your gains I'm high. I do. You want
me to adjust you or you want it sounds like has
Yeah, you're you're like you're like totally hazing right now.
But yes. Yeah, infinitely. But you might even be a little quiet
now. How about
There you go. Okay. My uh ever since the Windows update, my mic
keeps automatically adjusting. [__] No worries. Um
who who cares if she clarified to you after the fact. um her
her speaking to me like conditioned how I talk about this and
she's leaking the information to me and to other people. Sure.
I'm I'm I'm the I'm the leaker guy. Why would you Why would you
do that? It doesn't excuse anything that she's telling that to
somebody else. Who cares?
What if she misspoke? She didn't misspeak because in the context
of that conversation, she was specifically downplaying this risk
because I was bringing up like, "Hey, uh, this is this is really
like
this this is getting into a serious territory. You guys got to
be more careful with what you're doing."
And she was addressing that to me. She was also telling me, "Oh,
Pixie wanted money like from day one." Like that's where do you
think I got that from? I didn't make that up.
Okay. Yeah. Mr. Have you considered the possibility that the
fact that she explained all of this to you off of stream and
in private might be manipulative at all?
Uh, I mean, she said just say it's from me. Forget that. Forget
that. Here's here's the here's the part that matters. Regardless
of all of that stuff, she was telling Destiny behind everyone's
back, behind Pixie's back, "Hey, Pixie's got like no money. She
can't afford a $100 couch. You can buy her off for pennies."
So, there you go. like she sat any any settlement or or whatever
they imagined would happen is completely undermined by that because
she undermined her bargaining power. That's it. Like I don't
think I don't think she was like malicious. I think it was just
extremely stupid and irresponsible, but it absolutely did damage.
Like that that did damage. Okay. I don't remember it being phrased
that way and we'd have to go through it, but I feel like there's
probably more like it was it was it was written that way. Like
it's in it's in like these are the DMs that Destiny Yeah. You
remember when she's talking about how um she owes straight away
like 140 bucks or something and she's having to pay her in installments.
Yeah. She says she doesn't think she's in a good place because
of that. Yeah. Those aren't those aren't my DMs. Those are the
DMs that Destiny leaked after our videos launched. Yeah. So,
okay. I mean, we again, now I'm like at the point where we might
have to actually just go through these
because I I feel like was it not I I don't think that Strider
was trying to say, "Oh, you can buy her for cheap." I think Shredder
was trying to say paper school, which is like not explicitly
not cheap. She She's not saying that directly, Jessica. She's
saying by blabbing all of this information to Destiny unnecessarily,
she was undermining her Pixie's position. Also, watch this. This
this is this is super easy to get. Okay. Hey, it's okay. You
you'll pay for school. Okay, cool. Hey, you're not signed up
for school yet. Okay, go take your test and in a month you get
your results. We'll see how much how much you need for school.
Oh, I'm not going to pay you the whole thing for school. Just
a little bit more. But you're going to school now. Now you'll
take the small amount of money I'm going to give you. You see
the problem here? Like it's it's it's stabbing her in the back
regardless of what her intentions were. And so Okay, but I think
we were talking about her intentions here and like that are like
I think who cares?
She maybe had made bad decisions, but it isn't about her being
like a bad person, right? It's not about It's not about It's
not about like, oh, is is she an evil person who wanted to hurt
Cherry? No, she had a perverted desire to talk to these people
and be pixie. Sorry, Jesus. She had a perverted desire I'm really
sick right now. She had a perverted desire to be in like the
circle of these people and talk with them. Uh, and so she did
not intend to not Pixie in all of that. That that's what matters.
Hold on. Did you get the impression that she was like a big fan
of Destiny around this time? Aaron a big fan of Destiny. I I
don't think she needs to be a big fan of Destiny. I think she
really likes talking to them. She's not in there for the She's
not in for the money. She never made a She never made a channel.
She never made a way to actually um secure revenue from the attention.
She was in it because she liked talking to these people. She
likes being around them. She was living with Destiny at one point.
She doesn't hate him, clearly.
I didn't know that. I didn't know. You didn't know she was living
there? Lyken was working for him in in his house as a as a chef.
As a living chef, they had they had an apartment attached. They
had an apartment attached. I thought that they had their They
were They were in that whole They were in that whole complex,
weren't they? No, I thought they were in the same building.
As far as I know, they were not in the same building. My understanding
is they were in the same building. One of us is rock. So, yeah.
I thought When did they move into the same building complex?
Cuz I remember Lykan driving there, like having to drive there
for a while. So, maybe that changed.
I think ultimate does it matter because they were discussing
this. All of these things happened like she did disclose all
of this information to him that puts
people saying Lyan was in a different
I understand
Wait, no. Lyan was in a different building. Ly was streamed from
his house or from his apartment and it was a way apartment like
way.
It was not
Maybe they moved somewhere near the end. I I think you guys are
way off on this.
Like I watch Lightning from his apartment with like
point we're getting stuck. Yeah, this has nothing. It doesn't
matter what their uh what her interest or relationship toward
him or what Lyens was. It doesn't matter. Um we we can see exactly
what happened in their conversation. That should be an apartment.
It just wasn't like a $5,000 month apartment like Destiny's was.
Sorry. Um you guys go ahead. If we want to move it on to whatever,
I'm listening. I I'll be right back.
Oh, wait. Please. Is he listening? By the way, I don't think
so.
Always listening. Barely sentient. You weren't listening to me
in the first place when I brought this topic up. You What is
that about, by the way? How's the circulation? What was that
referring to? I didn't understand what someone said. Someone
asked you how's the circulation. I was very I was very perplexed.
Oh, when you lift your legs higher above like your like or it
improves your circulation.
Oh, that makes sense.
Kelly also has issues that are sometimes attributed to circulation
problems.
Yes, I have a microvascular disorder. What the [__]
are you doing?
Are you banging things? What is that? What the
someone chopping up my body? What is going on? [__]
hell. Brilliant. Yeah, I was just letting the silence hang to
see how long it Canada. So, he's uh he's he's trying to see if
he can get to my place before I before I talk to him. He's He's
trying to stay away for as long as perhaps we'll move on from
the topic they're in so he doesn't have to talk about I was getting
getting a drink. What are you trying to just go back to calling
me a again? Coke Zero.
It's really Pepsi Zero when I went to the store today. Yeah,
there's no Pepsi Zero when I went to the store today. So, I had
to get Coke Zero. It's very very rough time to be honest with
you. Sucks. All right. Okay. So, um,
so you, uh, you didn't you didn't switch your tune on Destiny
as, uh, as soon as the cherry thing came out. It wasn't just
because the cherry thing. You, uh, you had the same take as everybody
else, right? So, my my public take was, I think, essentially
the same as Queensman's after the New Year's stream. That's my
recollection. Okay. Uh, so you separated yourself after the New
Year stream some stuff. So, you separated yourself from Destiny
after the New Year stream because you saw that you had shared
this with the people around him. I said my public take on Destiny
was the same.
Yeah. So, you stopped associating with him after that point.
You didn't try to keep on uh Do you think Quman wouldn't have
gone into a call with Destiny if he could? Wait, Queen did go
into a call on with Destiny on my stream. I don't care. Talking
to you. Uh well, my claim is my take was the same as Queman's.
What was that? That basically almost certainly this was non-consensually
done. I didn't know for sure. You did. I didn't know for sure.
I said almost certainly done.
I did. Really? I knew you were talking to me. Yeah. Didn't you
get leaked DMs this? Weren't you What information? What information
do you think What information do you think I had that you didn't
have? Conversations with Straight Raid?
Conversations with Straight Raid. You needed You needed conversations
with Straight Raid to to know that the uh leaks of Molina were
non-consensual?
No. Were the leaks of those other people were non-conent? Hold
on. I covered the Molina stuff.
I don't. So, you you stayed connected with Destiny despite the
fact that he non-conensually shared with his ex-wife.
Yeah. Molina didn't want to pursue a case. So, what what does
that bear on you? Why'd you stick around?
Why' you uh because I think that this could be like a like a
major from him. And like I said, I said I would like go to Pixie
if she wanted to make a statement. I didn't reach out to Pixie.
I talked to Pixie, right? I'm not talking about I'm not talking
about Pixie. I'm talking about his ex-wife.
See, here here's the thing. You didn't need Pixie to make the
right decision in this case. You already knew that he shared
his ex-wife's without
you wanted me to basically what ban Desi from my and say I don't
associate with this guy anymore now that Molina has come out
and said this was non-consensual. I would expect that from By
the way, the Molina thing wasn't even the worst thing, right?
Um that's right. The worst thing was almost certainly the the
gay recordings, right?
You think so? Why? Yeah, the gay audio recordings.
Why Why is that the worst thing? Why is that the worst thing?
Oh, sorry. The references. The references because non-conentually
recording is obviously the worst. Yeah. Oh, that's more that's
more illegal. I I don't see how that's that's any any different.
How does that change it? The way the way
you could or I could explain to you my thinking on this, right?
Well, I don't I know what your think I know what your thinking
is already. That's that's not really an issue here because let
let's be let's be clear for a second. Like I I already know exactly
what happened. This is not like a mystery,
okay? I can tell you exactly what happened in January. You were
already trying to get with Cherry, which is one of the reasons
why when the lead call came out, you all of a sudden had to switch
your tune because you you were compromised. It's very simple.
You know that I don't want the real answers because I was I know
you and Cherry I do know Hey, I do as a matter of fact know you
and Cherry were not speaking at this time because she had some
very upset conversations with me concerning you about that time.
Yeah, that's what I thought. Yeah. Okay. So
yeah. So like like let's be clear for a second. Let's be clear
for a second. We are having this stream right now because you
are you are trying you are having this stream right I'm not going
to tell you. We are having this stream right now because you
are sort of blundering your way through to kind of like shrugging
off the fact of the matter which is uh you don't have any in
your life. So you said the magic word and now all of a sudden
you're in too deep. Um, and the person who freaks out about people
using her is freaking out about you using her. Okay. I mean,
that's a I don't mind you having that interpretation. Well, it's
kind of a fact. Last time you got laid the brief back of the
matter is you're literally You're literally just saying it's
a fact. It's a fact. Here's here's an additional fact. How much
money do you have that you could bet on this? How much money
do you have that you could bet on this? Here's an additional
fact. None. My channel is monetized. Here's here's an additional
fact. Here's an additional fact. Um, if Cherry had rejected you,
you would still be sweeping for Destiny 2 to this day. the exact
same way Dan is. What? Wait, do you think you think we were dating
in January? You think we had something romantic in January? Oh,
I have no idea. I have no idea. So, if she rejected me, I would
have taken back my coverage. Definitely before June. Definitely
before June. No, no. I'm just I'm just trying to I'm trying to
figure out what your take is. So, you just said I would have
gone back to sweeping for Destiny. So, I would have taken back
all my coverage and said, "Destiny, take me back." My take is
you're a slimy toad who would cover for a race. Oh, you just
you're going to totally back off of the the claim you just made.
So, you just said I'd be back to sweeping for Destiny. I would
be back to sweeping for Destiny. How? Back to sweeping for Destiny?
No, I think you would have continued sweeping for Destiny as
you did before. Okay. So, now you're claiming that before this
exact same
did. You played the exact same game that did the exact same game
did. I I hope everybody understand what he claimed.
Exactly what he claimed is that I would have kept sweeping as
in Cherry and I were dating before any of these allegations came
out. That is his allegation here. Uh, nope. I think you were
compromised before then. No, you just said we were dating. You
said if Cherry had rejected me, I would have been sweeping for
Destiny all the same, implying Cherry didn't reject me and we
were in a relationship. Nope. Nope. That doesn't relationship.
Nope. How does it not? Then give me give me another possible
thing there that Cherry didn't reject. Probably you were angling
for it. Probably you were angling for it. Probably you told Cherry
stuff probably you told Cherry stuff in trust that compromised
you. She knew too much about what you knew or she knew too much
about you or she had things that you said. Okay, it doesn't matter.
The point of the matter is it took until Cherry had a recording
of her despite the fact that you had knowledge of multiple other
people being recorded for you to change anything and now all
of a sudden we find out that you were uh you were uh telling
her telling her that gave her false impressions as to your investment
in a relationship and now here we are. You have any thoughts
on this? You think he's correct? My No, I'm not I don't know
what you guys are on on about. I consider Cherry a friend. I
support Cherry. Whatever Cherry says. Um that's Yeah, that's
what I got. So, what whatever you guys got is is your speculation.
What What about what Cherry said? Do you disagree with Chase
Talk? What about what I think you should trust her and that's
how she feels at this moment in time and I think you should trust
her on that. No. And if you want to look at me with like a If
you want to look at me, if you want to look at me, I don't want
to look. I really don't. Go ahead. No, go ahead. You have a point
you want to make. Go ahead. What specifically what factual statement
did Cherry make in any of her tweets that you disagree with?
Not what does she feel? What facts? I don't know what she factually
claimed. I'm not I'm not going to pull it up. You go one you
want to press. Uh I definitely read them when they came out,
but I don't You didn't send her You didn't send her a mountain
of DMs saying, "I love you. I love you, etc., etc." Yeah, that's
not a thing. I sent her that screenshot. Yeah, that's a that's
a screenshot of Yes. You, is it not? Said that earlier tonight.
Yes.
So, you said, but this is who who's in the screenshot? I'm losing
my mind. Myself and Cherry. This me. Yeah, I'm telling you those
screenshots are mine. Yeah, that those DMs are mine.
Okay.
I What do you I literally Are you okay? I literally said those
are mine. They're cringe. I realize that. I stand behind that.
What were you want? So, they were from you? Yes. Okay. So, are
you No, but it sounds like it sounds like you're trying to make
it seem as if you sent these DMs
to Cherry, but they were of somebody else. I had me blocked.
She had me blocked. So, I sent those DMs, but I was blocked.
So, I literally took a screenshot was like, these were the DMs
I sent. That's why I asked, "Did you just for clarification?"
So, just for clarification,
you said to Cherry, "Book another flight and come back. I need
you here." Yes. Okay, brother. We went over this like 2 hours
ago. Are you okay? Are you good? Do you have any points you want
to make? You're literally just read you're literally reading
these statements with incredul and nothing to back it up. Make
a statement. Take your position.
Say something. Yeah. You you lived in abject jealousy of Destiny's
access to women and you took the drippings when it was easy.
Okay,
that's it. Which Cherry is not, by the way. That was a pretty
disgusting thing you did to her. Do you just cherry is the only
Cherry is the only Cherry's the only person on the show Cherry
is the only person on this show with any kind of wit or intelligence
whatsoever frankly. Um she carried you when when you were President
Sunday used to say how it was and there are dozens of messages
no actual until the point where I was like I don't know why you
shut up. This is everybody must be so disappointed. Suddenly
just lying right now. I'm just lying about what? I'm I'm lying
about what? lying about the fact that you're pretending like
you didn't say I was funny and try speaking to me on multiple
occasions and I was just not interested.
Well, that was that was a joke, Kelly. That was that was I was
just joking. I was just joking. I was just joking.
Sorry. Yeah. Seems I like your accent though, but you're not
that funny.
You think you're funny. It's like you smell like hot dog water.
I do not I smell like sandalwood and roses. Thank you very I
hope to never be in the proximity to learn whether that's true
or not. Uh likewise. That was very distracting. Thank you for
that. Anyway, what was your point? I've lost it. Did you ever
have it? That's a guess we'll never know. Hell
of genuinely. Genuinely like let's let's look here for a second
though. That is that is all this is. Okay. you you smelled the
only access
that you have in in your proximity.
And it didn't matter if this was a a a victim of somebody that
you had been covering for until that point. Uh it didn't matter
if this person was rebuilding their life with their husband.
Um it didn't matter if this person was highly emotionally vulnerable.
And didn't matter if you you knew like clockwork that when you
toss this person aside, um she was going to go public and make
a giant issue about it. That's like that's it. You you let's
let's be clear. You do not give a [__] about any
of the victim. I would have to I would have to leak private communications
between me and her to disprove anything you're saying, but I
will let you come on and make these criticisms if you want. It's
fine with me. President Sunday is the moral arbiter of morality.
I guess the moral arbiter of morality. You have a way with What
else are you doing? You're judging him for not caring enough
about other
If that's not it, I I don't know. No, I'm saying I'm saying he's
aologist and a parasite. a rapologist and a parasite. No, everyone
here in some capacity is a parasite. So, what difference does
that make? I don't What difference indeed does that make? That
is the question
Yes. I don't Oh, but you you're just having to speculate to make
justical sound as bad as possible. You don't actually have any
basis for the things speculation taking place. Yes, it was all
speculation. Oh, none of it. Yes, it was. You just rambled about
how everything was based on the fact he was desperate to have
sex.
You don't know any of these things. You just said a bunch of
words. No, I think you're just projecting. When was the last
time you got laid Sunday?
Oh, wouldn't you like? Probably never.
Probably.
Um, yeah. I don't Do you have anything else you want to talk
about? Is that your only point? Not really. What So what what
is this though? Like so Cherry puts a bunch of those things up
and you have people call in to discuss it.
Why? Why do people strain? People wanted this people People literally
wanted me to address it. So decided So no, you had a vulnerable
person that you were in an interpersonal relationship with under
under
interesting circumstances. Why? Why is this content? Why is this
people want Why is this Why is this content? So why not?
You're the ethics board now as well.
Uh, nope. Then what's But I thought that's what I thought that's
what JTO was. Wasn't he uh wasn't he going all hard on Destiny
past few months? Yes, because he's trash. For what? For what?
What was I hardened on Destiny? For for the thing for the thing
you were defending him for, Jtock, which is statistical being
going around sending like
other people.
You can't you can't follow or secretly recording. No, no, no.
The I the thing I was defending you were very You were very specifically
I I could you were very specifically you were very specifically
hindering discussion of what was going on with Destiny's leaks
on stream and once again
I want you to I want you to find me
somebody I want you to find somebody it was only it was only
when it was only when find
all of a sudden when this person you were flying only when this
person you were flying out for suddenly had something leaked
that you suddenly turned on Destiny up until that point knowing
full well knowing full well there were multiple people that is
an implication that it was happening that's an implication do
you believe that is not before that that is not before the Destiny
stuff leaked
in there okay the Destiny stuff had been leaked for a while just
hold on I have been half listening uh half messaging people but
um I don't support anything that Sunday is saying I have no reason
to think any of this is the case. And but I'm also I'm not going
to say anything because like I'm not I don't know where Cherry
Cherry's at at the moment. So, um but I'm not co-signing anything
Sunday saying, but that's his age. I don't think I don't think
you were called upon to uh cosign anything. Okay. I'm just being
clear for the sake of people, you know. You weren't saying that
I was on on the same side as you. I just wanted to be clear.
Sure. That's all. But yeah, thanks for talking out the straight
raid stuff with me. I just wanted to throw that out there. I'm
not gonna have anything more to offer. Like I said, I support
Carrie and
um I I appreciate how respectful you're being on this stream.
Before you go, I should say I literally watched like 30 seconds
of a clip and then I said your stream was and I didn't watch
any of it. So that was my bad. Okay. I'm happy. You got the Kelly
Jean treatment. I'm I'm just apologizing. I was just like, "Oh,
you I go because Kelly said, why don't you call and I Kelly put
you in my sights." So, I'm sorry. Before you go, I Before you
go, just a heads up. Just a heads up. Yeah. Reminder that this
whole stream is making a spectacle of what Cherry was tweeted.
Cherry tweeted out. Oh, [__] That's the That's the
perfect That's the purpose of it. You boring idiot. I mean, uh
I can't I can't say anything more. You made a whole video and
called Pixie a extortion master trying to blackmail extortion
master. That's interesting.
Like
why did you have to make content about that? You I didn't make
nobody has to. Well, if I if I didn't make content about that,
Kelly, Jtock would still be covering for Destiny.
No, not if you left out the blackmail element. Wouldn't you on
about what? I said not if you left out the blackmail element
of that. That was like a whole narrative you male element. Yes.
If you don't know what to respond with, just repeat that. Why
do you Why do you think uh why do you think Nata Ariodite was
trying to get an explicit statement out of Cherry that she wanted
money instead of the moral improvement reassurances? Could you
imagine making money? Hold on real quick. Could you imagine making
money off of somebody who's like stated intention? Could you
imagine making content out of them? Uh, and you know, possibly
even the previous day or a few days before saying, "Man, I'm
not just going to violate their consent and go public with this."
I'd be a monster if I did that. Could you imagine doing something
like that? That would be wild. I see. You see the problem here,
JTO? Yeah. But the problem here, JTO, is that Yeah. Yeah, it
would be. Here's the problem, JTO. You're What do you think I
was saying that to Nick Doro for who was leaking it to me? What
do you think the purpose of him leaking it to me was? What do
you think I was telling him by saying that even if you're a psychopath
and are looking to your own self-interest, somebody else will
leak it first and make you look bad, so you have to go first?
He already did that. That was the purpose of that call. Nick
was the psychopath. You sped.
Okay. What does that have anything to do with what you choose
to your content? Did that clear you going live with your video?
What? Excuse me? Yes. I don't need I don't need I do not I do
not need clearance to go live with a video pointing out that
somebody else is manipulating people to avoid any sort of comeuppance
or any sort of accountability for sharing people in a vulnerable
position around him. I don't need permission for that. That was
you
were using
as a shield. You were using as a shield. You were using Pixie's
name as a shield. You were using Pixie's name as a shield so
that you could keep stay on the gravy train. Even though you
knew that Destiny's wife had the same things leaked, other women
had the same things leaked, other men had the same things leaked.
You didn't give a [__] until all of a sudden someone
in your personal friend group had something. So, you couldn't
play dumb anymore. You would have been licking his balls to keep
that income flowing. You just didn't have a choice. Hold on.
You know, I was like going live that day, right, to cover this
stuff the exact way I did. I was going live that day. Uh, probably
vitrial. What about the month before? How long were those leaks
out? How long Hey, here's a question for you, JTO. Who did you
warn first when the leaks came out? Pixie or Destiny?
I didn't know Pixie was in the leaks. You know that. Are you
You got the leaks before I did. Yes. I didn't get the leaks.
I didn't look at the leaks. Why do you think when I came on stream
to talk to Destiny, I was talking about the Lauren? I didn't
know about it. understand it was the Lauren Southern stuff that
I warned him about, right? Not the video leaks. Okay. So, after
the video leaks came out and everybody knew about it and you
absolutely did after the video came out, I me you already need
anything, let me know. And if you want to make a public statement,
I will be on your side. My platform is yours. Okay. So, so here.
So, ah, brilliant. Brilliant. So, knowing full well that everyone
around Pixie is encouraging her to not make a public statement,
you told her, "Hey, I didn't know that. Hedge your bets. If you
make a public statement, if you make a public statement, if you
make a public statement, if you make a public statement about
this [__] if you make a public statement, you already
knew that it was the case that uh Destiny's wife had no consent
for that. You already knew that Nick Doro was going out of his
way to cover for that, pretending that he had done his own little
private investigation and found out she was actually talking
about something with this leafy weirdo when that was not true.
You already knew that there were a bunch of people in that circle
who were all bending over backwards to pretend that none of that
happened. I knew that I criticized the point. Wait, I fine with
that. I criticized Nick for making everything out. Did you criticize
it before my video came out? Yes. I just I'm not I guess. Yes.
Really? Really? So, just just to be clear. So your your defense
in this case is you absolutely did know that Destiny's wife had
her without permission. I literally told you that you got to
make a choice here. You got to make a choice here, JTO. I literally
told you that either you knew No, no, you got to make a choice.
You got to make a choice. Either you knew that Destiny's wife's
was leaked without her permission by Destiny to someone who,
by the way, was very potentially underage or Well, that's it.
That's that's the problem, JTO. You can't criticize Nick unless
you already know. I'm not. I said I criticized that take. Hold
on.
Why' you criticize the take about him saying
was his investigation flawed? Did you follow through and make
sure? No. No. I actually looked into it. It can't it can't be
leaky. I think it's a mysterious third person snowball into the
next point. No, we're staying on this point. We're staying on
this point. If you're going to say that you criticized Nick Doro
before my video came out, criticize him on what I said. Oh, the
only thing the only thing the only thing you have to criticize
him on the only thing you have to criticize him on is that he
was misdirecting from what Molina was claiming about her being
leaked without her consent. But for that to be the case, you
would have to know in advance that they were leaked without without
her consent. I've always claimed to know. Yes. Which you've always
claimed to know. Then why did you stay with Destiny?
Why were you maintaining connections? Why didn't you make a public
statement?
Why didn't I make You didn't have to mention Pixie Jaw. You already
had a victim coming out and saying it was non-consensual. I literally
pulled up the full VOD and ran commentary over the VOD. Is that
not a public statement? Did the public statement include, "Hey,
Destiny leaked without his ex-wife's consent. That is unacceptable.
I will not be doing business with them anymore." included. Hey,
I've got people who are total pieces of people who have likely
kind of like
got those people on my server. I'll let Dusty come on. He'll
have to deal with commentary from other people just like you
did when Sunday came on. You're peeking really badly. Just you're
peeking really badly. Just so you know, you're really bad.
We can't hear you. We can't hear you. We can't hear you.
You can't hear me. Oh, am I muted? Yeah, you're peeking. You're
peeking really badly. I didn't touch your I didn't touch your
uh your volume. You You're just peing really badly. Poundland
microphone.
This is actually a very expensive microphone. This is a Discord.
Maybe we should get a refund.
Oh, I should get a refund. Yeah,
bro. I That's actually right-wing lunatic just made a point.
Not my point. Right-wing lunatic in the chat. Um, a lot of people
are like, "You should ban President Sunday. This guy totally
disregarded Pixie's consent. He's a complete piece of shit."
And I'm like, "No, he could be here."
Right. Same people have criticism for Aaron. I do let people
on who have like a wide a wide range of because if you're coming
into an open channel which this one actually isn't
you're coming to an open channel you're willing to take I remember
very clearly I remember very I remember very clearly I remember
very clearly you using the fact that oh oh this person's name
isn't out there yet in order to keep on talking to Destiny and
to silence people who are bringing it up. I remember that very
clearly.
I also remember once again that despite you claiming in this
conversation you claimed you claimed in this conver you claimed
in this conversation you claimed you claimed in this conversation
just now you claimed just now
you claimed just now no you claimed just now you claimed just
now
the topic talked about the topic you claimed you claimed you
claimed just now that you already knew that Destiny's wife's
was released without her consent You already knew this. Yes.
Yep. Yeah. No. Oh. Oh. Then then you thought she was a liar.
That's what we're running. I do think, by the way, yes. I thought
I thought there was a chance she was lying. Yes. You thought
there was a chance she was lying about her being leaked without
her consent. Yep. Wow. Did you ask a messy divorce? Cuz they
had a divorce. Did you ask her? I talked to I talked to Kelly
who's her friend. Yes. As I've been trying to say for the last
10 minutes, I was the one that was like saying things at the
time, right? He's like I was the one that said orbiter A and
then everyone got mad because they're like oh that's too obviously
pixie and then I got banned
like
but like I think said that he didn't like Molina right so he
wasn't sure
of course about yes
I thought she was the kind of person so like and I I don't want
to hammer this home at all but Molina has shared other people's
without their consent right or sorry images of them without their
consent. So I I was like, "Oh, she might not have like I was
like, "Oh, she might lie about this." Like she Well, there's
like a singular accusation from It's not anywhere near as bad
as Destiny. It's not even close to what Destiny's is, but it
did happen. It's almost certainly happened. It's also not necessarily
distribution, which is the problem, right? Yeah. Showing something
on your phone is not the same. No, it's just not the same.
But I didn't trust her. And by the way, that was wrong because
I had this idea that Destiny was at some level like a good person
who was like uh misguided. But but he doxed me on stream. He
do He doxed me on stream. I was in a haze. I was in a cult, bro.
You were in a haze. You were in a cult. Yeah. Like I was not
seeing things clearly. Yeah. This guy is clearly like a total
piece of [__] If I was seeing it clearly, if I could
identify the facts without like uh without being in that group,
I absolutely could have just called this guy out. Yeah. 100%.
So you're you're like you're like subhuman. Okay. Wow. I I I
feel kind of just gross.
So just being like, "Oh, this is the reality of like where I
came from. I was like a fat." You don't you don't understand,
Shander. He He had a hold of my mind. His fingers are laced into
my brain. God, you both are so obnoxious. Can you stop talking
over each other? Wow. You had like So So like the the the the
fist up your ass meme like a like a hand puppet. That That was
real. That was you.
Please don't talk about your kinks. You You get really really
mad about this, but Yeah. Like it was uh like I made major mistakes
there. Yeah. Being like a fan of this guy at all. Obviously,
he's a total degenerate piece of [__] Yeah. Obviously.
Yeah. How how stupid are you? Like Jesus Christ. Best time to
plant a tree. This is what you're This is what you're running
with. Best time now. This is This is what you're running with.
That's been like with my channel. Of course I was. Of course.
Of course, I was completely morally inconsistent and defended
atrocious behavior and and was silent when it was nakedly obvious
that this guy I was getting incidentally a ton of money through
my connection to was sharing with people around him without their
consent. I was just
brain damage. Okay, that works. That works. I'm fine. No, I'm
fine with that. That That's good. That's good. Yeah. Cool. I'm
I'm satisfied. That's That's cool. All right. Uh, by the way,
none of that is like you discovering it. I literally talk about
that openly all the time. Well, it was new to me. You have like
Do you have like anything interesting or novel to say? I don't
even think it's new to you. I feel like we've had this conversation
on stream before.
Uh I I don't believe we have. But as far as anything interesting
or or novel to say
uh dear God, um don't have again.
Okay. Don't even try. I'm going to take your word for it. Just
walk away.
Okay.
Well, Kelly
I hope your circulation continues to improve. Have a good one.
We'll talk to you later. Thank you. You can come back. I'm not
banning you or anything.
Bye. I just want to make him make him understand that he could
come back if he wants. I'm like not I'm not even mad about that.
I know where like I stand with all of this stuff. So, I just
don't think uh basically any of that affects me at all.
Unfortunately for him.
Okay, I'm going to go too. Love you. Bye. Bye. Gross. Gross.
Gross. Why did she do that? Why did you do that? That's so gross.
The [__] Why did you just say love you? She said
that. That was her soundboard. She has a soundboard of me. That
was you.
No. Or that was you. I don't know if that was you or her. I'm
pretty sure it was her.
Kelly's laughing though. Why are you laughing? That's
What a waste that the last 20 minutes of my life I'll never get
back.
I guess so. Well, that he could condemn you for having rose tinted
glasses on during a certain time, but he can knowingly release
Pixie's claims. Um, I mean, the way he sees it is Destiny's like
super evil, right? So, he's going to view the rose tinted glasses
as something that's incredibly harmful and like causing major
damage to people because obviously like I can even jive with
that because I'd say the rose tinted glasses are probably the
things, you know, with other people are probably what actually
um affected
what probably led to Pixie and like Cherry and other people being
victimized, right? If other people didn't have roast tinted glasses,
if other people didn't have that, wouldn't have been that bad.
You yearned to code, come back to the No, I like this. This is
good.
I don't know. Like maybe I should do a better job there of pointing
out that he had like no actual factual basis to stand on there
whatsoever. But hey,
everyone has biases. Being aware of them is good. Being able
to like look it back in hindsight and have retrospect
is like good. But the reality is everyone will always have and
continue to have biases and be a bit of a hypocrite sometimes.
is just like, uh, sure, Sunday's trying to act like you're dodging
accountability by stating that you were sympathetic to Destiny,
although like literally I think in the stream where I the stream
after the Sunday stream, I literally said, "Oh, I was way too
sympathetic to Destiny. I should not have been like this." And
then like after these leaks came out, I said, "Yeah, I I'm like
having my I'm like seeing clearly and I realized that like, oh,
you know, this shift when you don't view this person as like
somehow foundationally good."
Um, like obviously you can reevaluate a lot of their um
their actions
or I should have listened to Kelly.
Well, he also totally like misconstrued the Aaron convo, but
it's fine.
Sad. Wait, what about it? Even say Oh,
yeah. I don't know. I It's too bad. Kelly, have you reflected
on your proerodite bias recently? No, cuz I don't have one.
I am I haven't spoken to Aerodite in like four months, four or
five months since whenever my other Discord got like boked. I
don't have a relationship with anyone. I don't have a bias to
anyone.
Like all of these people could drop dead and it wouldn't make
much difference to me. I don't No, I don't have lice. I just
fiddle with my hair a lot because I'm not good at like sitting
still.
Do we have other people who are ready to come on? Are we taking
more calls than this? Oh god, this is actually going to be the
challenging one.
Okay,
Benny is in the waiting room right now and I feel like that is
going to be a tough combo. That's going to be a very tough combo.
I don't know. What does Benny think about? I don't want to talk.
Why? Why? What does he think about things? Benny's like uh Mr.
Girl light kind of. Um which I think he wouldn't take as a I
think he wouldn't take as a What does that mean? He makes songs
about being a like what does being mystic? What does that mean?
What is relevant to now? Uh what is it? Hold on. Oh, he's No,
Benny's just uh he he takes like very moral positions and he's,
you know, reasonably good at arguing for them. Benny, I will
pull you on. I'm going to pull this cosmic stray guy cuz he's
been waiting. Okay, this might be a mistake. I don't know where
this guy is in other servers and stuff, but I'll pull him in.
Okay, Cosmic Stray, you're on the stream.
What is up? I don't I know you were waiting for a long time.
I'm not gonna be able to give you a ton of time before I pull
Benny in. So, you got to go fast. If you're here, cosmic stray,
let me know somehow. Hello. Hello. Oh,
you are here. Hello. Uh, yeah. Yeah. Well, I first have to do
the disavow, right? So, I want to say that uh
is a better person than any of you. And sort of I know. Yeah.
I had to do it. Okay. I think
pretty sure, but go
Hope so. So, do you think it's right that you're turning all
of this into content? First of all, do I think it's right that
I show up to do my job and probably have to make a statement
on this? Um, literally everybody else has done this, but we're
like him making a response is it's fine. I literally shut up
to my job and I by the way um if I depending on how you could
handle this, it could be quite bad, right? I don't know what
you mean by that. I mean, we don't know what the other party
feels. Do you think you cannot make content on any emotionally
sensitive topic at all? Uh, I mean maybe. I'm not sure. I don't
I don't really know like the details of your uh I guess uh your
I I don't know what why do they never know the details of things.
They come in here to talk without knowing basic. You just wanted
to say you just wanted to ask me if it's okay to do content on
this while not knowing any details at all. Like the sound of
his own voice. Well, I mean, uh, I do have other questions about
your moral crusade and, uh, the little moral ground you have
managed to build for yourself, but I mean, first of all, I do
not I I wanted to sort of clarify why I you did the stream, I
guess. Okay. Um, so I wasn't going to respond to anything. I'm
responding to probably more than I planned to, but I figured
I should say something cuz some people wanted to hear my take
on this. Like eight other people did a stream yesterday and today.
Did you all give them a hard time for it? Did you all ask them
if they asked how Cherry feels about it? Probably not. Brilliant.
Sorry. Was I supposed to respond to that? I I I don't know what
you're talking about. Do you have a general problem? Sorry. Do
you have a general problem with people making content of this?
Like Destiny made content out of this even though he was also
named as a user in those tweets. Also, someone you emotionally
damaged. Sure. So, you you have a big problem with people profiting
off of this. So, you denounce Destiny, you denounce Ch, you denounce
all of these people for doing this? Uh, well, no. I mean I they
were not involved in uh making the situation happen. So I I don't
know how I can Okay. Destiny was
Destiny is named in a bunch of the tweets too. Did he actually
uh did he actually force you to to uh No, he's named in the tweets.
Hey, illiterate. He's named in the tweets.
I don't know what that has to do with anything. I mean, this
person he's literally named in the tweets as somebody who was
abusive. Do you understand? What are you saying? You're saying
that just because this person claimed that I'm supposed to take
that on Wait, what if that's what you're saying? Oh, just because
this person claimed that, I'm supposed to take it as fact. What
is your claim here at all? If that's your position, oh, I can't
I can't make any decision on this. What the are you doing? You're
here to make a moral to make a moral to take a moral position
to say something. Speak. I am I am saying something. I think
it is vile that you're using this moment to make you have no
consistency whatsoever on this and I've pointed that out to you.
How do I figure out how to find consistency? I literally just
said, "Do you denounce Destiny for this?" And you you just said,
"No, I said not involved in this incident or
responsible for it in any way and there's no evidence that he
is responsible for it." I I don't know. Am I supposed to take
the words like some words on a tweet? Are you claiming you did
not do this first of all? Are you claiming that you Dude, what
what do you think I did? I will just take the words of one tweet
but not the words
state of that person. Is that what you're claiming? I'm talking
about like cherrypicking. Jesus Christ. As in within the same
twice as well. Absolute idiot. Am I saying I'm saying we had
a fight? Um
yeah, and and this ended up happening after and obviously there
are a lot of I guess uh contributing factors and some of the
stuff with Destiny. Obviously somebody she cared about recording
her without her consent and spreading that without her consent
affected how she had this overall thought process. But it's fine
if you don't want to denounce that. It's fine. Um, I don't think
it's wrong to respond to this, especially when I'm not denigrating
her. I don't She says her. I'm not I'm not saying you should.
Also, there's audio of her being recorded and her clearly being
unaware of it, but it's whatever. Sorry. It's
Are you saying that those other people are responsible for this
situation in any way? Are you saying Chad or Destiny are responsible
for this situation in any way? I'm saying if your moral problem
if your moral issue with this is just I'm just I'm just narrowing
it down for you, right? And you've answered me so we don't even
have to continue to talk about it. But my questions were do you
actually have a problem with somebody making money off of this
off of somebody's like uh you know they're like let's say they're
venting tweets on Twitter. Do you have a moral problem with that
or is it just that like I'm named there? Okay. It's that I'm
named there. Okay. Hey, I I do not have a problem with somebody
covering drama. I am saying that you caused the situation and
now you're on stream for like I don't know 4 hours and then what
I I guess when I said that you think I should not have gone live
and responded to this. Uh I mean I you you're free to do whatever
you want. I'm saying that it's just morally responsible to do
so. What was he supposed to do? Just not go live forever or just
No. Wait.
No. No. No. What does morally irresponsible mean? What does morally
irresponsible
God simple means vile. I guess profiting off somebody's emotional
pain. I guess you're I guess you're farming subs or something.
I I don't know. Like you basically like did Destiny cover Cherry
about him and stuff. I don't like
I'm just I'm trying to find consistency here. When when Destiny
covers somebody having you know venting about him on Twitter,
it's also morally wrong. Right. Sorry. I Where do you think I'm
being inconsistent? I'm not like I don't understand. So you were
claiming that Destiny caused this. I'm just I'm asking you. No,
I just said when So again for consistency because you've come
in and you say Destiny's a moral person. So did he cover any
of
her? So when when Cherry vented about him
um ostensibly from her claims in a very similar way, did that
was that a problem? Was that morally disgusting to you? Because
you came in and said he's a good person, but he covered basically
the exact same kinds of tweets. No.
I don't know like what you're trying to say. Like he covered
them. He's in I don't know. He's in a lawsuit with the person
and they're like No, no, no. The 152 tweet. The 152 tweets. You
were the one the 152 tweets
were those the ones where was that the Dr. K tweets or what's
the 152 tweets? I have not seen them. Uh sorry. Can I pull it?
Is it on the stream? You're unaware. It's fine. He just doesn't
know the details to anything. He's brilliant.
Every time. Every single time.
To be fair, in in his defense, he came in and was like, "Desty's
like a morally better person than you guys." And you could only
claim that if you have no idea what his history is, right?
Do I get to some people for free now? Is that what happens? You
keep using that word, but you first of all, you have no moral
ground to use it. Second of all, why don't I a horrible
Why don't I
Why can't I say I get a free
And why is that? Anyway, I I mean, didn't you all spend like
the entire last months watching
a Revenge of Destiny inside your Discord server? I mean, for
research, you just you literally are just going to make up make
up malicious lies. That's very funny. The No. Do you have any
evidence of this? Do you have any evidence of this?
That's disgusting. You're saying you're investigating? We'll
just walk through this. Uh you'll you'll literally just explain
what your evidence is here.
so you're saying that you do not listen to any of the leaks?
If I didn't want to look at his in real life, why would I want
to look at a video of it? Gross.
Press somebody else. I did not listen. So what you just said
in a Discord server? You said we did this in a Discord server.
What are you claiming? Do you want to retry your claim?
Yeah. So this entire community has been going through the leaks,
have they not? I mean, I don't know. I all I see are not in a
in a if you want to make the argument in a coordinated way in
any way, can you just present some evidence
what do you mean? I I'm not a member of your Discord server.
I don't know what goes on in there. I just know. So why are you
claiming this without understanding what you're talking about?
Hold on. Why are you claiming this without stream and said that
you have looked through all the leaks? Is that my community?
Is that my community?
I've not gone through all the leaks. But even if it was, is that
my community? see the the catalogs of your video when you say
this. I I don't know. Can you pull up uh Is that my community?
No, I'm not pulling up a video. I'm not pulling up a video. I'm
asking you why you are here to make claims when you don't have
evidence for these claims or can't back them up at all. All right.
What brain DG is this? Let me just
Your claim was that my community watches these leaks together.
That is a claim Destiny's made without evidence and now you're
repeating it without evidence. You are a
But continue. Go ahead. I just I love every time a DJ joins my
stream and they just repeat Destiny uncritically without thinking
oh Destiny could just be lying to me making me look like a total
you just you it's not there for you. You don't see it. So you
guys get to come on and prove to all of my community why they
watch me instead. That'll just make things up about this guy.
Thank you for uh putting the boot in. Yeah, it's uh it's it's
very funny that uh you're you're able to do that. But just go
ahead and present any evidence for what you've claimed so far.
Yeah, I I'm about to. Yeah, before you went on your little tire.
Your just to be clear, your claim was my community watches these
leaks.
Yes. Yes, that is my claim. Okay. So, go ahead with the evidence
now.
Okay. So,
remove my eyes with a spoon on your channel where you claim to
have gone through all the leaks.
Okay. Link it. I mean, I don't know. There's one of your VODs,
right? Where you're I don't know whenever. I guess I don't know.
Was this I don't believe I've gone through all of the leaks.
So, I don't believe I would have claimed that. So, I want you
to just go ahead and link it. I mean, you should just pull up
the video. So, you're saying that you've not gone through all
the
I have not gone through all the leaks. Yes. Okay. So, but you
found from what I understand there's like 80 there's like Sorry,
not 80, like 30 videos of Desty jerking off. I did not watch
those 30 videos of this guy with his disgusting
nothing. Never mind. I did not go through all those videos cuz
I don't want to go through those videos cuz I don't give a Okay.
Okay. So, you accidentally found what you claim are problematic
ones. Uh, no.
I listen to things sent to me by people to verify and then pass
on to whatever party they were relevant to.
Um I didn't even watch any videos. So sometimes I heard audio
and I would pass it on to a relevant party.
Okay. So you're saying that your community So if you're asking
me if I heard some of these leaks? Yes, I did. Okay. So you were
saying that somebody So who sent it to you? You're saying somebody
So first of all when you're talking about somebody who sent it
byest
describing it. So, first of somebody who This makes me feel unwell.
Sorry. Who sent it to you? I mean, she keeps speaking. Uh, somebody
who sent who sent to them by Destiny.
The [__] are you? They call me she ass white. It's
been so long and you still have no idea what's going on.
Patience. There are several cases of these of these leaks where
I literally was told it's this person and I put them in contact
with that person and just said, "Hey, here's like a description
of the video that this person gave me. I've not watched it. Here's
the description. Um, do you think this is a video you were in?"
Oh, yes. Okay. Well, I'm going to I'm going to put you guys in
a three-way call and I'm going to let you guys share that amongst
yourselves. So, so you're claiming that literally like good Samaritans
in your chat gave you these links and then you passed them on
I guess the effective so people reached out through Twitter discord
and said hey Destiny sent me some that I believe to be non-consensual
and I said oh do you have any like identifiers for this and then
basically I would say okay if it's like if it's this I've heard
like this I I literally basically tried to keep track of with
watching as little of it as I possibly could what like things
were around Yeah. or people. I mean, the most obvious case was
people just Can you show Can you show me these Twitter links?
Because when you're talking about this, your community in the
chat is posting about descriptions.
I mean, your
go
and my chat is posting about these.
Go ahead. When you're going over the links, your community like
I don't know like in a part from February, I think nobody's watching
revenge in this server.
You're yapping about nothing. You are just claiming that I I
I I You have no evidence. The onus on evidence is not on us.
It's on you.
No, the honest is on you because you have You have
that not how that works. We're We're actually like dancing around
this. You made a positive claim that we as this community watch
the leaks. Produce your evidence or leave. Produce your evidence
or leave. That you just made a claim about the community, not
just me. Produce your evidence. the community does it or leave.
The community chat on the screen of this VOD shows when you're
talking about it. Link the VOD. Link the VOD. You've got like
15 seconds to link the VOD before I move on to Benny. Oh, I mean
I I don't know. I guess I can uh What VOD? Hold on. You're saying
this VOD? Like you're looking at it. Link the VOD. No, I'm saying
a VOD from February. I I don't I'm not I literally just followed
you 10 minutes ago. Link the VOD. Link a VOD from February that
you're talking about. Link anything you're talking about.
Where are you referencing this from? You're just making this
up. I'm I'm literally going to your channel. Like literally just
I'm I'm not part of your server. So Wait, what? No, no, no. I'm
asking you where did you get this from this idea?
It's in your vaude. It's literally your VOD has a chat that's
displayed when you're talking. You said you just got here. You
haven't watched it. Go ahead and tell me where that bot is that
you're talking
It's a It's a video from February. I have watched said video.
Like what part of that are you not understanding? Okay, go ahead
and link it. Also,
that's what I'm trying to do. Oh, sorry, sorry, sorry. You said
in my Discord, by the way, you're talking about people in the
chat now. That's a different thing. But I do think there would
be people in the chat who might be referencing these videos,
too. No. Well, lots of them are. There might be people here who
reference it as well, right? There are lots of people who would
know what's in these things from like the the documents as well,
right? What documents?
But hold on. You said we watch it together. We've watched these
things together
as and your Discord. Yes, that is my claim. No, that's stupid.
So, I just wanted to make it clear that like I wasn't pushing
back against, oh, people in my community may have seen the leaks.
I I have no way of evaluating that, right? You my the claim I'm
pushing back against is that there's some coordination by my
community to watch it in a Discord or together in some way, which
is insane. Yeah, I'm sorry. So, so I want proof of that. I don't
want proof of you finding leak links that like there's a chat
where people talk about leaks or something. I want you to give
me the evidence that my Discord is coordinated to watch these
together. Discord is server. Yeah, you don't have it. Just say
you don't have it. Just say you've never had it. Just admit that
you've never had it. Sure. I never had it. How about that? Brilliant.
Okay. So, why did you claim it? Uh because I mean it it is true.
I I don't know. Like literally, I can't find your true. Why do
you think you claimed it without evidence? You said obviously.
No. No. Okay. So, your your claim is like I don't have any direct
evidence, right? So, you're claiming that I don't have any evidence.
You don't have any evidence? Oh, dunk. I know what he's talking
about. I know he's talking about Kenny's Kenny's comment. I know
what he's talking about. But he doesn't know what he's talking
about. Which is the funny part. I just like pointing out that
these people never know what they're talking about. This is very
funny, right? Like, you would think it would be embarrassing
for you to show up somewhere and go, "I know you did this bad
thing." And then people say, "How do you know that?" And you're
like, "My dad told me." You loser. My dad told me. It's like
like I would be embarrassed to do that, but this guy shows up
and does it and just feels no shame whatsoever. It's incredible.
I mean, why would I feel shame? Like, you literally have a video.
Why would Why would you feel shame for showing up and making
a claim that you can't back up and you only believe based on
somebody else who makes things up constantly, who just maliciously
lies all the time? So, you're claiming that when you're talking
about this, your chat on screen does not say these words. Is
that Is that what you're Is that what you're claiming? or you're
saying that these chatters are not part of your discord. So there's
no way I can talking about Kiwi Farms is not the same as watching
revenge, sharing revenge or downloading revenge or looking at
it in a discord like
very boring the same. Um people in my community may have seen
these leaks. There's no coordinated effort to watch these leaks
or like oh you have to watch these participate in the community.
There's nothing like that. Um you're trying to imply that you
have no proof of that. If you get proof, you can come back. But
for now, I'm going to talk to Benny because he has, you know,
at least
a hundred more IQ than you. Okay, good luck, Benny. What's up?
Welcome back, buddy. My leg is going. How's it going?
I don't want to talk to you cuz I feel like you're going to be
like you're going to like uh Benny looks to me like you're on
the other side of the river. This might be This might be where
the bridge burns and I'm like very scared. I hope it's not where
the bridge burns. We'll see. Why Why do Why do you think that?
I don't understand. because I think uh I think your your friend
Max is like a no compromise kind of guy and I'm not a no compromise
kind of guy. But anyway, go ahead. No, no, no. You go. You go
for it. You go for it. Wait, wait, wait. I want you to expand
on that a little bit. No, don't just speak, Benny. Ch. I think
you're probably going to say, "Oh, you know, he's